[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات في العناوين
متفيد يهدد بتحويل اوكرانيا لرماد اذا
استهدفت
القرمزيلنزكي يقر بصعوبه المعارك
عقوبه اوروبيه جديده لعرقله الاله
العسكريه الروسيه سقف اسعار النفط يدخل
حيز التنفيذ
يتهم الصين بامتلاك اسطول من مناطيد
التجسس وبكين تصف الاتهام بالمبالغه
مليشيات عراقيه تختطف الناشط جاسم الاسدي
قرب العاصمه بغداد وتقتاده لمكان مجهول
صباح الخير البدايه من تطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه وتاكيد استخباراتي بريطاني على
تقدم روسي في بخموت الاوكرانيه حيث اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بان عزله مدينه
باخموت تتزايد وذلك بعد احراز القوات
الروسيه تقدما طفيفا في محاولاتها لتطويق
المدينه الواقعه في اقليم دومباز وبحسب
الوزاره الطريقان الرئيسيان المؤديان الى
المدينه مهددان بشكل كبير بعد التقدم
الروسي واشارت ايضا الوزاره البريطانيه
الى ان طرق الامداد البديله متعدده عبر
اوكرانيا ومتاحه للقوات الاوكرانيه بدوره
هدد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديميدف
باستخدام كل انواع الاسلحه وتحويل اجزاء
من اوكرانيا الى رماد ردا على تسليح كيف
باسلحه غربيه رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي اوضح
ان بلاده لن تتفاوض في حال تم استهداف شبه
جزيره القرم وهدد بتوجيه ضرب انتقاميه
باستخدام كل الاسلحه بما يتناسب مع
التهديدات مؤكدا ان القرم هي روسيا واكد
ان الهجوم عليها بمثابه الهجوم على روسيا
اما رئيس مجموعه فاجنر مشاهدينا ايفيني
بريكوجين قال ان هناك معارك قويه في الجزء
الشمالي من مدينه بخموت شرقي اوكرانيا
واكد ان قتال شوارع يدور في بخموت مشيرا
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت لم
تنسحب منها بعد ياتي ذلك فيما افاد مراسل
العربيه ان قوات فاجنر توسع حصار فخموت في
الناحيه الجنوبيه الغربيه لتصل الى اطراف
مدينه كوستي نيفيسكا في الاثناء نقلت
صحيفه
خسائر روس البشريه في حربها على اوكرانيا
بلغت ما يقرب من 200 الف جندي وفقا لبعض
التقديرات واضافت ان هذه الحصيله من
المرجح ان تستمر في الارتفاع مع استعداد
الكرملين لهجوم جديد في الاسابيع المقبله
ونقل التقرير ان الجيش الامريكي يقدر ان
عدد حاول قتله تخطى حاجز المئه 180 الف
على الرغم من ان المسؤولين اكدوا ان هذه
الارقام ليست دقيقه وتتطابق هذه الحصيله
مع تقديرات وزير الدفاع النرويجي الذي قال
الاسبوع الماضي عدد الجنود الروس الذين
قتلوا او اصيبوا يقرب من 180 الفا وقدر ان
مئه الف جندي اوكراني قتلوا او جرحوا
للمزيد حول تفاصيل المعارك على الارض تنضم
الينا من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم
اهلا بك معنا كاتيا اذا ما اخر التطورات
الميدانيه الوارده لديك
صباح الخير فاطمه بالفعل مقاومه مقاومه
شرسه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه للقوات
فاجنر الخاصه كما تحدث الان رئيس
الذي قال ان هناك معارك شرسه في شمال
مدينه بخموت هناك قتال للسيطره على كل حي
هناك قتال شوارع في المدينه ولكن هناك في
الوقت نفسه مقاومه شرسه من هذه القوات من
قبل قوات الاوكرانيه هناك طبعا كانت قد
تحدثت
السيطره على بعض المواقع في هذه المدينه
والتموضع في فيها من قبل هذه القوات على
الحدود الشرقيه لمدينه هذا من جانب ومن
جانب اخر
الانفصاليون في دونات كانوا قد تحدثوا انه
تم قصف دونات كان الانفصاليه من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه يوم امس ب 45 مره
باطلاق لاكثر من 200 قذيفه كانت استهدفت
المناطق منها منها
ايضا تم استهدافها
بقذائف اوكرانيا من بينها قذائف ايضا تعود
الى حلف الناتو كما تحدث الانفصاليون هناك
في في طبعا المعارك كما تحدثت جاريه هناك
كما تحدث
رئيس
الخاصه اما سياسيا طبعا كما تعلمين نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي كان قد حدد بانه
سيحول او روسيا ستحول اوكرانيا الى رامات
في حال استهدفت الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالتحديد هنا ردا على امكانيه استهداف
شبه جزيره القرم كنا قد شهدنا في وقت سابق
طبعا ابن العامل العام السابق كنا قد كانت
قد استخدمت القوات الاوكرانيه شبه شبه
جزيره القرن قامت بقصف جسر القرم وهذا ما
ردت عليه طبعا روسيا بقصف جميع محطات
الطاقه في اوكرانيا كان هناك قصف عنيف
لذلك تهديد اليوم ياتي ايضا بالرد على
تهديدات الاوكرانيه المستمره لاستهداف
الاراضي الروسيه في ظل طبعا
احتمال الكلاب اوكرانيا في وقت لاحق من
الاسلحه ومنها الاسلحه بعيده المدى فاطمه
اذا على هذا ربما تعزو القوات الروسيه هذا
التقدم قبل وصول هذه الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا ربما كاتيا ولكن ما ابرز
التصريحات الوارده من المسؤولين الروس حول
هذا
التزويد الغربي لاوكرانيا
ويعني ماذا يقولون ما تصريحاتهم هل لك ان
تجمل لنا هذه التصريحات
فاطمه الجانب الروسي كان واضحا دائما بان
العمليه العسكريه لن تقف وانها ستستمر حتى
تحقيق جميع الاهداف روسيا كانت قد تحدثت
ان هذه
الاسلحه التي ترد الى اوكرانيا ستكون هدفا
شرعيا للقوات الروسيه طبعا حتى هناك كان
من يتحدث عن ان هناك جائزه جوائز سيتم
توزيعها الى من سيصيب الدبابه الاولى
دبابه اليوبارد الاولى او ابرامز
الامريكيه التي ستصل اوكرانيا سيكون هناك
جوائز للشخص الاول الذي سيقوم بتدمير هذه
الذبابه وهدم ايده ورحب به الكريم الذي
قال انه سيكون حافزا للقوات الروسيه لان
تقوم بقصف هذه الدبابات التي ستصل في وقت
لاحق كما ذكرت لك الى القوات الاوكرانيه
فاطمه شكرا لك من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعمه
[موسيقى]
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقرير يوثق خسائر
اوكرانيا البشريه
الوضع الاوكراني واحد من ثماني حالات
طوارئ صحيه حاده عالميا
اكثر من 14 الف قتيلا ومصاب من المدنيين
و17 مليونا بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه
سبعه ملايين ونصف المليون لاجئ اوكرانيا
مشرد في انحاء اوروبا
[موسيقى]
448 هجوما بالاسلحه الثقيله على منشات
الرعايه الصحيه باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تقرير منظمه الصحه اشعل مواجهه جديده بين
واشنطن وموسكو
موسكو شككت بدوافع التقرير السياسيه
ووصفته بالمعتمد على روايه الجانب الواحد
فيما دعت واشنطن الى سرعه تحديثه لتوثيق
الحوادث في اوكرانيا منذ سبتمبر
كان ذلك عن موسكو وننتقل الان الى كيف حيث
اقرر الرئيس الاوكراني فولدمير بان الوضع
يتعقد على الارض في مواجهه القوات الروسيه
مؤكدا ان الوضع صعب جدا في باخموت وفوقار
ولمان ايضا في الشرق وغيرها من المناطق
خلال 346 يوما من هذه الحرب كثيرا ما قلت
ان الوضع على الخطوط الاماميه الصعبه نحن
الان مجددا في مثل هذه اللحظه لحظه يحشد
فيها العدو المزيد والمزيد من قواته لكسر
دفاعنا ان الوضع صعب جدا الان في بخموت
ولمان في الشرق وغيرها من المناطق
في سياق اخر مجرد الرئيس الاوكراني
فولدمير زيلينسكي سياسيين سابقين من
الجنسيه الاوكرانيه وذلك في احدث خطوات
لتطهير البلاد على حد وصفه من التيارات
المواليه لروسيا وذكرت وسائل اعلام
مشاهدينا اوكرانيه ان القائمه تضم العديد
من السياسيين الكبار منهم نائب رئيس
الوزراء السابق بالاضافه الى وزير للتعليم
والداخليه اسبقين حول ذلك ينضم الينا ملكي
الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك معنا محمد اذا
تطهير سياسي ما زال مستمر في الداخل
الاوكراني وتقدم روسي حول باخموت وتصريحات
يؤكد ذلك كيف نفهم تاكيد زيلينسكي على
تقدم القوات الروسيه وهو الذي كان سابقا
ينفي اي تقدم للقوات الروسيه
هناك حصار شديد ومحاولات الاقتحام مدينه
باخذ من اجلها الشماليه من يعني الطريق
الممتاز من السوليدار من شمال مدينه باخت
ومن اجلها الشرقيه من طريق يعني تقع بعض
الكره الاتيه من مدينه وايضا مدينه
العسكريه مستمره الجيش الاوكراني اكد ان
الجيش الروسي يقوم بقصر جميع خطوط التماس
بالمدفعيه وراجمات
جراد لا تتوقف منذ يعني ثلاثه ايام حتى
حتى هذه اللحظه يستمر القصف
وهذه الراجمات هي يعني تطلق في كل رشق
اكثر من يعني من 20 الى 30 صاروخ يطلقون
في دفعه واحده على منطقه يعني مساحه
جغرافيه معينه وهذا يسبب دمار كبير في
الابنيه السكنيه وبالمراكز العسكريه حيث
يتواجد الجيش الاوكراني طيب محمد هل من
تصريحات او ردود فعل ربما حول تصريحات بان
استهداف القرن سيجعل من اوكرانيا رمادا
يعتمد السياسيين الاوكرانيون من المكتب
الرئاسي والوزراء وحتى يعني الضباط
الامنيين والمتحدثين باسم الجيش وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه بعدم الرد على تصريحات
الذي يتوعد كل فتره عند كل حركه او يعني
اطلاق مساعدات اعلان مساعدات غربيه
لاوكرانيا يطلب بان هذه المساعدات سيتم
تفجيرها ويلوح باستخدام السلاح النووي بين
الحين والاخر ولكن الجانب الاوكراني لا
يعير اهميه احدى القنوات ردت بفيديو ساخر
بالامس
الاوكرانيه حيث يعني نشرت عمليه اطلاق
الصواريخ عمليه اطلاق صواريخ ومسيرات
اوكرانيه على شبه جزيره الكرم وايضا اعاده
نشر فيديو تفجير جسر يعني هي ردت ان
القوات الاوكرانيه عندما تريد تنفيذ عمليه
لا تنتظر يعني تصريحات مثل هذه شكرا لك
محمد البابا على هذه المعلومات
الاتحاد الاوروبي مشاهدينا يبدا اليوم
رسميا تطبيق قرار تحديد سقف للمنتجات
النفطيه الروسيه عقوبه جديده تقول اوروبا
انها ستعرقل الاله العسكريه الروسيه في
حين اقللت موسكو من تاثيرها على الاقتصاد
الروسي
مئه دولار لبرميل الديزل وخمسه واربعون
للفيول وغيره من المنتجات النفطيه منخفضه
الجوده هذه هي الاسقف التي قرر الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرضها ابتداء من الخامس من
فبراير
2023 على ما تصدره روسيا من مشتقات
البترول
الاوروبيون سيسمحون للبلدان غير الاوروبيه
وشركات نقل النفط التي تتعامل مع روسيا
ابرام عقود التامين والتمويل مع مؤسسات
غربيه فقط اذا احترموا السقف المقرر
اوروبيا حسب مراقبين فان الرد الروسي على
العقوبات الاوروبيه سيكون بسيطا لكن صارما
موسكو ستوقف او تحد من تصدير الديزل
لاوروبا التي تغطي نصف حاجياتها من روسيا
وبالتالي ستتعطل مصانعها وستقف الشاحنات
والحافلات لكيلومترات
المحطات الوقود
البدائل المتاحه لاعضاء الكتله الاوروبيه
كلها بعيده وغاليه ومعقده لوجستيا اذا ما
لجات لاستيراد الديزل وغيره من مواد
بتروليه من بلدان كالهند والصين وبالتالي
ستكون الاقتصادات الاوروبيه اذا ما طبق
القرار اول متضرر من العقوبات
اقتصادات ما زالت تعاني من ازمه الغاز
الروسي التي ادت الى رفع تكلفه التدفئه
وانتاج الكهرباء في اوروبا بعد قطع روسيا
الامداداتها من الغاز المسال فستكون
اوروبا حسب متابعين كمن اطلق النار على
رجله مرتين انس نماسي العربيه
الولايات المتحده وجه التحذيرا ثالثا الى
تركيا من احتمال خرقها للعقوبات على خلفيه
تعاونها الاقتصادي والتجاري مع روسيا رغم
العقوبات الغربيه المفروضه عليها والتي
اعلنت انقره من البدايه انها لن تكون جزءا
منها وجاءت تحذير الجديد مشاهدينا من جانب
نائب وزير الخزانه الامريكي لشؤون الارهاب
والاستخبارات الماليه برايان الذي اجرى
مباحثات في انقره واسطنبول على مدى يومين
نيلسون لفتاه الى ان النمو الملحوظ في
الصادرات الثانويه التركيه واعاده التصدير
الى روسيا خلال العام الماضي يجعل القطاع
الخاص التركي بشكل خاص معرضا لمخاطر
العقوبات نشرتنا تستمر وفيها
محكمه تركيه تقضي بسجن اربعه عشره طالبا
جامعيا لمشاركتهم فاحتجاجات ضد قرار
للرئيس اردوغان
احييكم من جديد اصدرت محكمه تركيه قرارات
بحبس اربعه عشره طالبا جامعيا لمشاركتهم
في احتجاجات على قرار الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بتعيين احد اعضاء حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم رئيسا للجامعه واصدرت
المحكمه قرارات بالحبس تصل الى سنتين ونصف
بتهم عده منها مخالفه قانون المظاهرات
ومنع موظف من اداء واجبهم اما وزير الدفاع
التركي يخلصي اكار فقد اعلن ان الوفود
العسكريه لتركيا وسوريا وروسيا ستعقد
اجتماعا الشهر الحالي لتطوير الحوار
الثلاثي والذي انطلق نهايه العام الماضي
وبحسب اكار لوسائل الاعلام تركيا ستجتمع
الوفود الفنيه من وزاره الدفاع
والاستخبارات مع تاكيده لاستمراريه الحوار
من دون ذكر اي تفاصيل عن موعد ومكان
الاجتماع وقد عقدت في نهايه ديسمبر الماضي
مشاهدينا في موسكو بعد اقتراح من الرئيس
طيب اردوغان عقدت مشاورات بين وزراء دفاع
روسيا تركيا وسوريا في اطار عمليه التطبيع
العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق حيث ترى انقره
ان هذه المشاورات قد تخلق ارضيه لتسويه
سياسات شامله للوضع في سوريا بما في ذلك
حل مشكله اللاجئين
ازمه اسقاط منطاد التجسس الصيني توفاقم
التوتر بين واشنطن حيث اتهم مسؤول في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
اتهم الصين بانها تمتلك اسطولا من مناطيد
المراقبه للتجسس في سماء خمس قارات وقال
المسؤول الامريكي لوكاله رويترز ان
المنطاد الصيني الذي اسقطه الجيش الامريكي
هو واحد من ذلك الاسطول واضاف ان المنطاد
لم يكن مرتبطا بالارصاد الجويه بل ارادت
الصين استخدامه للتجسس على مواقع عسكريه
حساسه ونقل مسؤولون امريكيون مشاهدينا عن
الجيش انه سيحاول سريعا انتشار المكونات
الرئيسيه لمنقاط المراقبه الصيني من بين
الحطام قباله سواحل ساوث كارولاينا بعد ان
اسقطته طائره مقاتله من طراز اف 20 2 في
المقابل الصين ادانت بشده للهجوم العسكري
الامريكيه على منطاضها الذي تشتبه واشنطن
بانه لا التجسس الخارجيه الصينيه ذكرت
انها طلبت وبوضوح من الولايات المتحده
معالجه الامر بشكل مناسب وبهدوء ومهنيه
وضبط للنفس متهمه الاداره الامريكيه
بالمبالغه في رد الفعل وانتهاك الممارسات
الدوليه بشكل خطير واضافت الخارجيه
الصينيه في بياننا بكين ستحتفظ بالحق في
اتخاذ المزيد من الردود الضروريه وكانت
طائره مقاتله مشاهدينا طائره مقاتله
عسكريه امريكيه اسقطت ما يشتبه بانه منطاد
تجسس صيني اثناء تحليقه قباله ساحل ولايه
يوم السبت بعد اسبوع من دخوله لاول مره
المجال الجوي الامريكي الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن اوضح انه اصدر امرا يوم الاربعاء
الماضي باسقاط المنطاد لكنه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه اوسط بالتريث حتى يمكن القيام
بذلك في منطقه مفتوحه فوق المياه لحمايه
المدنيين من سقوط اي بقايا من المنطاد على
الارض
هكذا انتهت قصه المنطاد الصيني في الاجواء
الامريكيه صاروخ واحد اطلقته طائره اف 22
اسقط المنطاد في المياه الاقليميه
الامريكيه قباله سواحل كارولانا الجنوبيه
وذلك بتوجيه من الرئيس جو بايدن كما اكد
بيان للبنتاجون
يوم الاربعاء عندما اخبرت بموضوع المنطاد
امرت باسقاطه باسرع وقت ممكن وقررنا ان
يتم ذلك من دون الحاق الاذى باي شخص على
الارض وقررنا ان افضل وقت لذلك هو عندما
يصبح فوق المياه على بعد 12 ميلا
ازمه المنطقه في الاجواء الامريكيه لم تضع
حدا الانتقاد الجمهوريين لاداره بايدن على
تاخرها باسقاطه حيث اتهمها رئيس لجنه
القوات المسلحه في مجلس النواب مايكروجرز
بانها كانت تامل في اخفاء فشل الامن
القومي عن الكونجرس والشعب الامريكي
الجمهوريون لن يتحكمون في الكونغرس واشخاص
يحشدون للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله لذا
اعتقد ان اي شيء يفعله او يفعله
الجمهوريون فسيهاجم طرفان بعضهما حطام
المنطاد المتواجد على عمق 47 مترا سيرسل
بعد انتشاله الى مختبر كوانتيكو التابع
للاف بي اي في ولايه فيرجينيا ليتم فحصه
ومعرفه ما قيمه المعلومات التي صورها
الصينيون
المسؤلون في الباندا شددوا على ان المنطقه
لم يشكل تهديدا استخباراتيا كبيرا
للولايات المتحده لاعتقادهم بان
التكنولوجيا الموجوده فيه اقل تطورا مما
تمتلكه الصين اصلا الحسين الطول العربيه
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
من بكين معنا الصحفي نادي الرونج اهلا بك
معنا سيد نادر اذا ماذا خسرت الصين حقيقه
بعد اسقاط هذا المنطاد
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
اولا هذا يعني
لاغراض المدنيه ويعني لا يجب اسقاده بقوه
لان حتى حسب
[موسيقى]
اداره
الدفاع الامريكيه لا يشكر على تحديدا على
المنشات العسكريه والسكان في الولايات
المتحده ثم اعتقد هذا ايضا بسبب تم التطور
توريط السن في السيرام بين
الحزبين الجمهوريه الديمقراطي داخل
لذلك هو يريدون ان يستطيع الاحاديث لفرق
المزيد من النقود على السين لتقديم
في الحب مفاوضات مع الجنب في
طيب سيدنا نادر هل تسمعني
نعم طيب لماذا تنشر بكين وبحسب التصريحات
الامريكيه اسطول من هذه المناطيد حول خمس
قارات
لا توجد ادله تدل على ان الصين تنشر مثل
هذه المناطق في خمسه كرات فهذه هذا النوع
من المناطق والسين صنعتها من اجل او
الارصاد الجويه والبحوث العلميه
للاتحاد
الاجواء الجويه لاي دوله ذاتيه السياده في
اي سياق يمكن ان نضع سيد نادر هذا التصرف
اسقاط المنطاد ودخوله للاجواء الامريكيه
على العلاقه بين بكين والصين خصوصا مع
التصعيد السياسي الذي نشهده بعد الغاء
لزيارته الى بكين
اولا هذه الحادثه حادثه يعني غير متواقعه
يعني بدون
مقصود ولكن هذه حادثه بالفعل اشارت يعني
المزيد من التواتر بين الجانبين الصيني
وامريكا واصلا يرجو هذا السبب الى عدم
الثقه بين الجانبين وخاصه الولايات
المتحده ولم
هناك تحليلات هنا في الصين بان
اصلا الوزير بلينك لا يريد الزياره في هذا
الوقت بسبب الضغوط ضغوط من حيث الجمهوري
وكذلك تم استقلال هذاك الحوجه وهناك صراع
بين الحزبين
ولذلك
هذه
الاتجاه حتى يعني في المستقبل العلاقات
الصين الامريكيه تتوقف على الجانب
الامريكي فاذا استمرت يعني
احتواء الصين اعمال لاحتواء
ستتاح علاقات بين البلدين ولكن هذا لا
يسوق لصالح والجانباني ولا يسبصالحه
للعالم كذلك اذا
ما ابرد الوارده من الجانب الصيني سيد
نادر حول اسقاط هذا الصاروخ وما الخطوات
المتوقعه التي يمكن ان تتبعها بكين على
اثر ذلك
حسب متحدثه باسم
وزاره خارقه تصريحات بيان من وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه بان
تعارض هذا الساحه
التحركاتها
تتخذ جميع الاجراءات
للحمايه الحقوق
لشركاتها
وكذلك
النصائح الجوهريه لها طيب شكرا لك من بكين
الصحفي النادر رونق
كيف يعمل منظار التجسس لمحه ادق تظهر
كيفيه استخدام هذه المعدل القديمه في عالم
التجسس الحديث عندما اكتشفت الولايات
المتحده الهيكل الطائر فوق اراضيها امتنعت
عن اسقاطه معلله ذلك بانه لا يشكل اي
تهديد على سلامه الناس على الارض كونه
يحلق على ارتفاعات تتجاوز حركه مرور
الطيران التجاري والعسكري بكثير
المناطيد عاده تعمل على ارتفاع من 24
كيلومترا الى 37 كيلومترا وفي منطقه تعرف
بجاره الفضاء حيث لا تطير الطائرات
التجاريه ابدا على ارتفاع يزيد عن 12
كيلومترا و500 متر
اما بالنسبه للطائرات المقاتله فهي تحلق
بعلو متوسط بين الارتفاعين حده الاقصى 20
كيلومترا بينما ترتفع الاقمار الاصطناعيه
عاده الى 241 كيلومترا ولدت تحليق في الجو
تستخدم هذه المناطيد مزيجا من التيارات
الهوائيه وجيوب الهواء المضغوط التي يمكن
ان تكون شكلا من اشكال التوجيه ويتم ملء
هيكل المنطاد الرئيسي بغاز الهيليوم او
الهيدروجين وهما اخف من الهواء والذين
يعدان وقودا لمحركي المنطاد ويعاد شحنهما
بواسطه الواح الخلايا الشمسيه مناطيض
التجسس تحتوي ايضا على انظمه الرادار
المحموله جوا ذات القدره على تزويد الطاقه
من الارضي بمعلومات استخباريه عن مساحات
شاسعه علاوه على ذلك يحمل منطاد التجسس
كاميرات للرؤيه الليليه والنهاريه وفيما
يتعلق بالبالون الصيني الذي شغل مؤخرا
فحجمه يعادل ثلاث حافلات في حين ان
بالونات الطقس عاده ما يتوسع عرضها الى
نحو سته امتار اذا ماذا يحدث عندما ينهي
المنطاد رحلته اذا لم يتم اسقاطه فسيسقط
تلقائيا في مكان ما
نتابع معا بعد الفاصل
وفاه الرئيس الباكستاني الاسبق برويز مشرف
بعد معاناه مع المرض عن عمر يناهز التسعه
وسبعين عاما
[موسيقى]
يهدد بتحويل اوكرانيا لرماد اذا استهدفت
القرمز يقر بصعوبه المعارك
عقوبه اوروبيه جديده لعرقله الاله
العسكريه الروسيه سقف اسعار النفط يدخل
حيز التنفيذ
الصين بامتلاك اسطول من مناطيد التجسس
وبكين تصف الاتهام بالمبالغه
مليشيات عراقيه تختطف الناشط جاسم الاسد
قرب العاصمه بغداد وتقتاده لمكان مجهول
كن من جديد اعلن الجيش الباكستاني عن وفاه
الرئيس الاسبق للبلاد بوريز مشرف عن عمر
يناهز 79 عاما في احد المستشفيات في دبي
واكدت السفاره مشاهدينا السفاره
الباكستانيه في الامارات اكدت ان وفاه
الرئيس الاسبق الذي حكم البلاد لقرابه
العشر سنوات على عن جانب بعد معاناه طويله
مع المرض
النشط البيئي العراقي المعروف بجاسم
الاسدي مشاهدينا تعرض بالامس يوم السبت
للاختطاف على يد قوه مسلحه واقتيدا الى
مكان مجهول وقال ناظم الاسد شقيق الناشط
المختطف ان قوه مسلحه اختطفت شقيقه قرب
العاصمه بغداد واقتادته الى جهه مجهوله
معنا من البصره شاكر عواد اهلا بك معنا
شاكر اذا ما تفاصيل لهذا الاختطاف ولماذا
يعتقد اخاه انه مختطف
بالحقيقه الامضاء متضاربه وحتى انه يعني
مصادر تقول انه اختطف قبل اربعه ايام ولما
احس المقربون منه انه في حاله خطره بداوا
بنشر
اختطافها عبر وسائل الاعلام او عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي من اجل يعني الضغط على
القوه التي اختطفته لاطلاق صراحه هكذا
يعني الانباء تشير في الناصريه بعد انه تم
الاتصال باخيه
ويعني اعطى خيوط قليله عن احاديث الاختطاف
فقال انها قوه مسلحه اختطفته
بالقرب من مشاعر بغداد يعني بين محافظه
واسط ومحافظه بغداد بالاضافه الى للمعلومه
بانه كان على وشك ان يستلم منصب رفيع
يشرف على اهوار التلمج التي تقع بين
محافظه واسط والديوانيه يعني هذه كان قريب
على وشك ان يستلم هذا المنصب اي منصب وهل
هناك خلاف معروف حول هذا المنصب شاكر ربما
لحد الان
بانه هناك خلاف
يعني المقربون من جاسم الاسدي لا يريدون
ان يعني
صوره كبيره ربما يريدون ان يحافظون على
انقاذ لان كان حسب المصادر كان هناك تفاوض
مع القوه المسلحه من اجل اطلاق صراحه وهذا
ما عرفناه يعني من مصادر قريبه من عائله
الاسدي ولكن لغايه الان لم تتضح الرؤيه
حتى انه يعني الاختطاف كان قبل ثلاثه ايام
او اربعه ايام ولحد الان لم يعرف او لم
يتم تحديد من هي القوه او العائله تفاوضت
مع من اجل اطلاق سراحه واي شروط الموافقه
عليها معلومات
ربما حول ان كان ياتيه تهديدات قبل
الاختطاف فما هي مطالب المختطفين
لحد الان مثل ما قلت لك لم تشير يعني لم
يشير المقربون لم يعطونا معلومات فقط
بانهم بان الحادث على وفق استلامه منصب
الاشراف على هور الدلمس النفو قاطعا قالوا
بان الموضوع لا يتعلق بهذا الشيء اذا ما
هو ما هو سبب اقتياده لان
جاسم الاسدي كان اخر تغريد له هو يعني
مشروع مع الامم المتحده من اجل انقاذ
الاهوار في جنوب العراق وفي المحافظات
المجاوره بالاضافه الى زياده وهناك ابحاث
وهناك ناشطون جاؤوا اليه من اجل المساهمه
بعمليه
هذا هذه يعني اعمال يعني انسانيه من اجل
انقاذ
الاهواء انسانيه فلماذا
اجابه على الاسئله لغايه الان وننتظر يعني
الايام او الساعات المقبله ان تبوح باشياء
اخرى نعم
ماذا عن وضعه الاجتماعي هل لديه عائله من
زوجه واطفال
بالتاكيد ولديه عائله وهو مقيم في الاهوار
بالقرب من اهوارش ولديهم منظمه دائما ما
تقوم بابحاث مع منظمات اجنبيه وامم متحده
وحتى يعني مع سفارات
السفاره الامريكيه يعني من اجل ابحاث
تتعلق في الاهوار العراقيه وانقاذ الاغوار
العراقيه وحتى موضوع التراث العالمي
انضمام الاهوار الى التراث العالمي كان هو
من ضمن مشروعه من اجل انقاذ الاغوار
والمحافظه عليها شكرا لك من البصره شاكر
عواد على هذه المعلومات
ننتقل مشاهدينا من العراق الى قبرص حيث
يدلي الناخبون في قبرص باصواتهم اليوم
الاحد وذلك الاختيار رئيس جديد في
انتخابات من غير المرجح ان تسفر عن فائز
واضح مما يمهد الطريق لاجراء جوله ثانيه
في الثاني عشر من فبراير ويدلي نحو 561
الف قبرصي يوناني باصواتهم في الانتخابات
التي تجري بعد انتهاء رئاسه الرئيس
المحافظ الحالي نيكوس انستاسيا انستازياس
التي استمرت فترتين فيما يتنافس اربعه
عشره مرشحا على الفوز برئاسه
صحيفه وولز جورنال اشارت الى ان الولايات
المتحده تفكر في وضع بعض الشركات الصينيه
المختصه في تصنيع انظمه المراقبه
والكاميرات في لائحه العقوبات وذلك لدعمها
للنظام الايراني في قمعه للمظاهرات
واستهداف المواطنين بالتزامن مع مضاعفه
صادرات هذه الشركات لطيران خلال العام
بتقنيه صينيه يراقب النظام الايراني
مواطنيه وفي بلد يواصل انتفاضه ضد القمع
ترصد كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه مطالبين
بالتغيير نحو مزيد من الحريات دور لبكين
في طهران رفضته الولايات المتحده التي
تدرس فرض عقوبات جديده على شركات مراقبه
الصينيه بسبب زياده مبيعاتها لقوات الامن
الايرانيه باكثر من الضعف عام 2022
وفقا لولو قد تركز العقوبات على شركه
وهي شركه لتصنيع معدات المراقبه تبيع
منتجاتها الى وحدات الحرس الثوري
اشارات ايضا لدوري شركه اخرى تدعى من خلال
مشاركه مدير مبيعاتها في مؤتمر امني نظمته
الشرطه الايرانيه الى جانب لقاءات مع رئيس
جهاز امن الدوله الايرانيه دور الشركات
الصينيه في ايران قد يعرضها لعقوبات حجبها
عن النظام المالي الامريكي من قبل وزارتي
الخزانه والخارجيه الامريكيه
استخدامات كاميرات مراقبه الصينيه في
ايران يتم بالتعاون بين اجهزه الامن
والتلفزيون الرسمي الايراني من خلال
توظيفها للتعرف على وجوه المتظاهرين ومن
ثم اعتقالهم الى جانب استخدامها في اشارات
المرور لمعاقبه النساء اللائي لا يرتدين
الحجاب وفي ظل محاولات الشركات الصينيه
الالتفاف على العقوبات الامريكيه وانكار
ايران المناق تصريحات مسؤوليها باستخدام
كاميرات المراقبه تبقى كل من بكين وطهران
تحت مجهر امريكا والغرب الرافدي لسياسات
البلدين عن السمان العربيه
[تصفيق]
في اسرائيل خرج الاف الاسرائيليين للاسبوع
الخامس على التوالي في مسيرات احتجاجيه
تمديدا بالتعديلات التي تسعى حكومه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الى ادخالها في
النظام القضائي
رغم
اياكي
[موسيقى]
القبه الحديديه وبحسب وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه نقلا عن الجيش بان نظام القبه
الحديديه اعترض طائره مسيره فوق قطاع غزه
واسقطها قبل دخولها المجال الجوي للبلاد
ونقلت مصادر صحفيه عن الجيش قوله انه لم
يتضح ما اذا كانت المسيره تنتمي لاي فصيل
فلسطيني وان بلديه
سدريوت اكدت للسكان انه لم يتم اطلاق
صواريخ باتجاه المدينه الواقعه شمالي قطاع
غزه
والى السودان حيث افادت وسائل اعلام
سودانيه بان سته مبعوثين دوليين سيزورون
العاصمه الخرطوم يوم الاربعاء القادم لدعم
العمليه السياسيه ولبحث استئناف المساعدات
للبلاد وذكرت صحيفه السودان تشربيون ان
وصول المبعوثين الدولي يتزامن مع زياره
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرافروف الذي سيصل
الخرطوم ايضا في نفس الوقت لاجراء محادثات
مع مسؤولين في مجلس السياده وفي الخارجيه
ولجنوب كردفان قال موسى جبر ان الاوضاع
الامنيه تحسنت بعد اعلان حاله الطوارئ في
الولايه منذ عشره ايام
اصبحت التقارير اللي بتجينا من المحليات
تؤكد انه في تحسن كبير جدا عكس ما كان قبل
اعلان حاله الطوارئ
كما اشار والي جنوب كردفان الى ان زياره
عضو مجلس السياده لفريق شمس الدين كباشي
تركز على الجوانب الامنيه والسياسيه في
الولايه كما ستشهد الزياره مناقشه
التحديات التي تمر بها الولايه الزياره
عندها ملامح ومعالم ومزايا متعدده كانت في
السابق زياره الطابع تنموي خدمي اجتماعي
الان اضفنا لها عاملين اساسيين هما العامل
الامني والعامل السياسي والزياره لها
مدلوله في انها بشكل حرائق مجتمعي لكثير
وتضخ
دماء زي ما بقولوا بالضخ حيويه للمجتمعات
اللي ظلت تنتظر انه جهه مسؤول رفيع
المستوى من المركز
منذ اكتوبر من العام الماضي الصراع بين
مكونات مجتمع لقاء وبولايه غرب كردفان
بظلال على الاوضاع الامنيه والانسانيه
ماذا عن مئات بنزوح لولايه جنوب كردفان
بمحليه كادوقلي لنتعرف على الاوضاع
الانسانيه في معسكر الميناء البري
لسان حالي اهل لاقاوه الذين دفعهم تزعزع
الامن للنزوح شرقا نحو معسكر الميناء
البري بكادوبلي
ابرز ما يقلقهم غياب ابنائهم عن التعليم
هنا يبحثون عن من يلبي رغباتهم ورغبات
اهلهم في العوده الى الديار عايشين والله
الحمد لله بامن وامان حصل فينا في اصلا
كده اتنسينا ما فينا اي شيء الحمد لله لكن
الوسيله
بنرجع بس بلدنا
من مجينا لنا اربع شهور
اطفالنا والله تعبانين
من ناحيه التعليم ما لاقين تعليم وما
مرتاحين دايرين باي شكل كان نرجو نرجو
عشان يرجعوا المدارس بالرغم من رغبه اهل
لقاوه في العوده الى ديارهم الا ان محليتك
دوبلي ترحب بهم مواطني لقاهم واحنا بنظلهم
كمواطنين لمحل لجنوب كردفان ان شاء الله
واحنا ضيفناهم باعتبارهم جزء لا يتجزا
مننا وهم اهلنا ومرحباهم ان شاء الله
مخاوف النازحين متعدده شحوا الطعام خصوصا
والموارد عموما وهي تحديات تواجه المعسكر
والله الوضع في المعسكر يعني هو كويس لكن
مفوضيه العون الانساني حريصه على معرفه
الوقائع على الارض لان الوضع تصعب سيطره
عليه استقبلنا عدد 1400 اسره تعالي لنا
سبعه
الفرد في يوم 13/10 اسره الاحداث القبليه
الاخيره في محليه الاقاوه ويمكن تم تدخلات
واضحه وكبيره جدا جدا من الحكومه الولايه
ومنظمات الدوليه لا يزال الامل رفيق
النازحين هنا فقبل يومين فقط وهب الله
العالم هذه الطفله تهددها امها وتمنيها
لقاء لقاوه هي وبقيه الصغار في القريب
العاجل
الصعوبات التي يجدها النازحون في معسكر
المينا البري كثيره جدا
ابرزها بحثهم عن الغذاء وكذلك اطفال لا
يجدون مدارس ليتعلموا فيها
مواقف ومناظر انسانيه تستحق الاهتمام سالم
الهاشمي العربيه جنوب كردفان
وقررت اللجنه الوطنيه للحزب الديمقراطي
اقرت رسميا تعديلا واسعا لمواعيد
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب والذي اقترحه
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الذي سيستفيد
منه في حال ترشح لولايه ثانيه حيث وافقت
اللجنه على اقتراح يسمح كارولينا الجنوبيه
ببدء الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الديمقراطي العامه المقبل وهو تغيير يمنح
وزنا اكبر للامريكيين من اصل افريقي في
اختياري مرشحهم الرئاسي اما في ولايه
اوهايو وبنسلفينيا حيث اجلت فرق الطوارئ
السكان او اجلتهم من منازلهم في نطاق 1.6
كيلو متر من الحريق الذي تسبب به خروج
قطار عن مساره الجمعه وذلك بعد ان اشتعلت
النيران في عدد من مقصورات القطار في بلده
ايست بالستاين شمال الغربي في
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا توصلت دراسه جديده نشرتها
المجله العلميه رويال الى مقدره النمل عن
كشف اورام السرطان من خلال حاسه الشم
كاداه سريعه فعاله بدلا عن المعدات الطبيه
باهظه الثمن لتمييز الاورام البشريه
الدراسه العمل العلميه دربت النمل في ثلاث
جلسات فقط حتى
تتمكن من قضاء 20% من الوقت بقرب الرائحه
المستهدفه دلاله على التعرف على الورم
السرطاني ورغم ان نتائج الدراسه واعده الا
ان الفريق البحري اكد اهميه زياده العمل
قبل الانتقال الى التجارب السريريه
نهايه النشره الى العناوين
متبادل يهدد بتحويل اوكرانيا لرماد اذا
استهدفت
القرمزكي يقر بصعوبه المعارك
عقوبه اوروبيه جديده لعرقله الاله
العسكريه الروسيه سقف اسعار النفط يدخل
حيز التنفيذ
والبنتاجون يتهم الصين بامتلاك اسطول من
مناطيد التجسس وبكين تصف الاتهام
بالمبالغه
ميليشيات عراقيه تختطف ناشط قرب العاصمه
بغداد وتقتاده لمكان مجهول
دمتم بخير